welcome back to new rock stars and with
LeapFrog being the Frog God who
manipulated the premarital Union between
she home and Daredevil in episode 8 of
She-Hulk Matt Murdoch is for sure going
to have a lot to confess and he gets
back to New York
all this did unsanctioned pre-marital to
the Archdiocese of Los Angeles sponsored
dude the Archdiocese is going to come
down hard on his ass it's just a
Catholic sanction show now
yes we're we're sponsored by the
Catholic Church
that'd be terrible because no Matt
didn't get his ass kicked he for sure
got that ass slapped let me tell you
that's a Thunderclap right there right
shut the truest Thunderclap of them all
that's why he was Walking Away In A Daze
he's just like I can't hear [ __ ] I got a
that Thundercloud just really took my
ears out but what if Matthew and
Jennifer's sin had more consequences
than just Daredevil spiritual life
somehow who wrote this morality
on this show I'm obsessed with this I
can't get through this intro with the
strange faces
I've ever had to try I'm dying this is I
wrote it with Matt's spiritual life
threw him with him in him in the unity
of the holy spirit all glory is on
others Almighty father forever and ever
die Christ
Jen Walters will come again
and again
she said she was satisfied so we have to
assume Murdock I mean I mean definitely
he doesn't have all his other senses got
to be amazing right right the clicks you
can literally hear her heartbeat so he
can like I was thinking about this I was
like okay okay what if what if on the
off chance you had to fake an orgasm
with Matt Murdock you can't you just
can't so but but because he's a
superhero I would like to believe that
he follows the heartbeat pattern and
figures it out if he's doing a bad job
he's gonna know you don't have to tell
him you don't have to have that awkward
conversation he can just be like you
know what babe I am gonna move a little
bit more to the left let's go I respect
that when I I think you're dead on we
haven't even introduced the host but I
would like to do my first Rogue Theory
and that's that Matt Murdock has to fake
his orgasms because he's so in tune to
the Biometrics of his partner that it it
becomes almost like a science project
for him and less pleasurable like where
he's like I can tell how close she is to
getting off yeah all right is that a
rogus or a bogus or not I would say that
that's a rogue I can't believe we
haven't introduced ourselves
I think we have in our own way
but what if somehow Matt Murdock got the
She-Hulk programance my baby she devil
hybrid Gino this is right okay the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
Mt and going with me today is the
wonderful Whitney van leningham what's
going on with me hey I'm good just
thinking about Matt Murdoch's dick
oh my God me too dude listen that is
that is just another hallway fight he
won am I right exactly
we're talking about this earlier uh the
vagina is the the first hallway that we
go through
Mother Nature oh my God
I was having a nice little Thursday
then Jessica had to call out and now I'm
in this chaos we're talking we're
listening I just discovered what sex was
last night by watching She-Hulk episode
eight now I'm excited
and of course the totally awesome Tommy
Bechtel what's going on Tommy Mt big
head gang peaches and cream I've missed
you my brother you know you know when
we're not together I get a little weaker
like Superman moving away from the sun
it's been too long there are imposter
big head gang members on Twitter trying
to join in now the big head gang is
inclusive you can join in but you can't
replace either of the founding members
we are exactly we have founding fathers
in our own way there is a musical coming
out about the big head gang
exactly except no imitations are bigger
than Mount Rushmore we've got giant
heads but you know empty I gotta say and
I don't want to put any pressure on you
a lot of the rumors are coming around
because you we can't see you in person
the people are theorizing that you
actually have a tiny head and we only
see you zoomed in
exactly listen the objects in my room
orbit around my melon because of the
gravity that my melon produces I don't
know what that means
I got it and I liked it but also the
Bodacious Brandon Barrack what's going
on Brandon what's up
[Laughter]
one thing about Brandon that you can't
tell on camera he's got triple F's
we take them out in post but yes let's
lead this to our first topic of today
um this is me being extra bro because
I'm usually not this role because my
theories but I'm gonna go extra super
Rose today because I believe for this
Rogue theory that Matt Murdock and
Jennifer Walters will have a baby
together and like I think that this
would be a really great way to to just
like keep them connected and like it
would just be like hey
um like and like I would love to see
what a Matt Murdock Jennifer Walters
baby would be like in terms of like if
would this person have superpowers like
what would their superhero career look
like like would like it would just be
super cool to have like a I don't know
like a half Hulk like super soldier type
being
um be born from this really fun Union of
two people with great chemistry but like
I think that's a really fun way to like
because like I feel like
um you know with the introduction of um
love in Thor love and thunder
um I think that she's moon dragon I feel
like something's going to happen where
like all these kids are going to be
introduced as kids and then like Kang is
Gonna Come and like time travel is gonna
like Fast Forward their aging process
and now we got like older people it's
like all right we have the next
generation of Avengers and I think that
Matt Murdock can do it for Walters could
um have their own baby much like you
know Luke Cage and um Jessica Jones will
one day have their baby which I I'm
waiting for that for so long beautiful
babies those are like seriously two of
the most attractive human beings on
planet Earth exactly a little mixed baby
would be so adorable
um it would it would piss off the tiki
torch whites which is my favorite part
um leave my customers alone
[Laughter]
Hawks will not replace us
okay but like so what what powers
Defenders
a low question just a little one yeah
yeah so I think I I think I know where
you're going with me so when mats
because like Matt's super hearing Powers
probably wouldn't get passed on because
that's a result of his well he's gonna
take his child to factories to chemical
plants
these bats in the back of a truck he
just rear-ends it like let's go he put
some freaking on chemicals in like the
whatever the baby gets baptized in it's
like all right
they're hanging out at landfills
yeah yeah doing dumpster diving in just
mountains of broken glass exactly Broken
Glass Broken space
broken a super soldier serum syringes
just like all right here you go just use
this uh what are you gonna say sorry no
I I think we all cut Whitney off Whitney
was originally going to ask a question
right or did I no that was my question I
was wondering what like how and what
powers okay I got that so my question is
is this a big zoltar machine scenario
where they all get bigger via wish or is
this a is this a reverse big top peewee
where they all you know in big top
peewee the sequel to peewee's Big
Adventure the uh the old people all
turned very young it's just a reverse
where they they like eat magical pickles
and become large how how are we how are
we making these children adults I guess
is my question is it via arcade on a
boardwalk or is it via wishes I I feel
like it's gonna be via time travel
um
they go to play an arcade game they
think oh this is gonna be fun but
actually it's a Kang variant in the
arcade game possessing the body of the
zoltar
come on guys it's obviously believe it
I wouldn't believe it she's absolutely
right I think that Kang will leave a
Jumanji board absolutely oh my God for
children
this is becoming Saint elsewhere where
every everything is because of King like
every movie that's ever existed somehow
a result you did right the universal you
know I think that's pretty inaugurated
the Royal tenant bombs
yeah yeah that's true we have we have
Kang the blank for Julie and that's
oh yes
and it is only King also did the first
two Daredevil movies he did yeah
was there two or just one of those well
there was like the sequel oh right but I
don't there's not much Daredevil in the
Elektra spin-off I don't recall I don't
think it's Ben Affleck wanted to get
back into the suit uh empty in this
scenario I like this I mean my one
question my one thing against this is
Matt's a smart guy you know he's he's
Catholic he knows he's he's sinning when
he does this thing but it's cool because
you can just go say I'm sorry and then
the priest says God says you're okay but
Matt Murdock would know if Jennifer
Walters is ovulating not to get to In
The Weeds here uh I think he he could I
I think he if he can hear a heartbeat he
could probably hear if an egg is uh
resting in her Fallopian tubes or not uh
if it is dropped from her ovaries and is
ready to go he might also be able to
smell her pheromones she's like
ovulating at this point also I think
we've established it's like a bear like
a bear I think we've established here
that Matt Murdoch is the king of the
Rhythm method right oh yeah
at all he knows yeah there's no way his
pullout game is weak pull and break
quite literally also my girl Jen Walters
ain't dumb enough to accidentally get
knocked out right okay thank you she has
an IUD she regularly she's not leaving
it up towards checked for STDs yeah
she's not leaving it up to the guy to
bring protection she's protected she
also I you know strongly believe uh
would have uh you know I write a right
to choose that she could or could not
keep the baby I mean she's a busy lawyer
it was a one-night stand yes he's great
yes he's wonderful see where the
relationship goes but staying together
for a baby isn't a good reason to stay
but isn't there something special about
a woman who Waits I'm just kidding sorry
that was a joke I've seen how many
people she's hooked up with like she
clearly has a plan for one night stands
and I respect her I was gonna say if
when Jennifer Walters does choose to get
pregnant and you have uh you're growing
a child inside of you uh at some point
becomes a fetus when Jennifer Walters
becomes the Hulk does the fetus oh
or does it
Focus because in theory because in
theory she's sharing she's sharing blood
she's sharing all of her we gotta bring
her questions
oh dude yeah I think if you have I think
the baby is hulking out also would you
like to see the baby uh which is fine
but what if the what if a fetus is able
to Hulk out when the the mother is not
home oh God that could be dangerous
right this is a horror movie yeah
oh my God
this is the danger
she Faces by your future child is a
nightmare that I never want to explore
no nope no I should Jen nope nope
Brandon very delicately explained to me
how children are made yesterday so I
just learned all this no he's telling me
that they can be Hulks
if we kissed hard enough
and really mean that listen Tommy babies
can be Hulks and pigeons can live in Los
Angeles I don't know what else yeah
that's true I'm sorry stop lying
it's pigeons that bring the babies
that deliver the babies to the doorsteps
exactly in Los Angeles specifically
shouts to the pigeons the storks have
gone extinct because of pollution so the
pigeons that yeah we hunted we hunted
the storks uh for their feathers and for
their cute little uh blankets that they
carry
Geeks that went into our beaks that
tasty bricks
too
delicious but also like this is you know
sort of getting it like super specific
but I guess that ship has already sailed
but like so you know that from the uh
started recording MD yeah two people
clinically diagnosed with mental
illnesses
and then be like we gotta stick to a
scripture you have to just expect
nothing good can come over
nobody else wants to sit with us
literally they got one of our other
co-workers came by the other day and was
like we should do like a decorate your
office contest for Halloween and then
they looked she looked in her office and
she goes oh you and Whitney will go way
too far with it
we'll kill a person
[Music]
but no um I so we know from the 2008
Hulk movie that like you know Bruce is
trying to cure himself from this disease
and he's like trying all these like
foreign
flowers and stuff but his body rejects
it so like can she even get pregnant uh
because like if you have I think she can
I was thinking about empty because like
yeah like the Hulk I think She-Hulk is a
different scenario right because Hulk
and Bruce Banner it's two separate
personalities and like Hulk Hulk's whole
thing is like survival right and that's
why he won't let Bruce get hurt where
like the second Bruce is in danger he
hulks out right and like he saves him
and we saw it in uh uh uh Avengers Age
of Ultron right uh Hulk gets punched in
the face spits out a tooth but Bruce
isn't missing a tooth because Hulk can
grow it back immediately but I think in
like Jen scenario her body wouldn't
reject necessarily A Child because it's
natural and it's like supposed to happen
yeah uh it might reject see this is
where I'm starting to think Whitney the
um if she if Jen Walters is on birth
control does like the Hulk when when she
helps out does that like does that like
nullify it oh [ __ ] right right yeah damn
does it destroy the the hormones in her
blood that's preventing her from getting
pregnant
from like an IUD then the right that's
right it destroys it like how no the
cervix goes like no
Brandon to your point though there is
the uh the uh one of my I think I'm not
usually a snickler for like deleted
scenes I'm usually like all right they
were deleted for a reason the deleted
scene from Infinity War when uh banner
and Hulk have their like one they they
have their like because they can take a
conversation yeah you're a smart Hulk I
wish that scene was in there I know we
don't necessarily need it for the story
but we need it for She-Hulk like it
weirdly would make She-Hulk much more
explainable because she skipped all the
steps that Banner had to go through and
just became a smart Hulk immediately so
I think that smart hooks have a certain
amount of body autonomy like I think
they did right they're not necessarily
like nothing can hurt us they're just
like we know nothing can hurt us so we
can prevent it but we also know how to
be rational I think Tommy it's actually
Hulk and banner that are the weird ones
because Banner had this personality in
his inside of him him when he gets the
gamma radiation and becomes Hulk and
like that personality is what was like
absolutely the gamma and like become it
it created a separate personality so Jen
skip those steps because you don't need
to I think if you if you inject 100
people on the street you know 99 of them
are gonna be fine we're talking family
we're talking Family Feud rules we're
talking Family Feud we rejected 100
people Steve Harvey with the syringe
you keep putting me away from it I will
stay away from the needles please but I
do think Tommy I you're right they
skipped all those tests because she
doesn't need to because like for her
it's just like oh I'm still the same
personality but I do think that her the
Natural Instinct of your body to protect
you right uh the fact that you faint uh
a person can faint when in danger
because your brain is basically being
like your brain is separate from your
your personality and your conscience
right your brain will do anything it
takes to keep itself alive including
shutting down your limbs uh making you
faint in public like whatever it needs
to do your brain does not care about you
your brain is your enemy okay it will
kill you
said that I've been on record chains
yeah it will kill you to stay alive your
brain is against you okay Consciousness
in your brain or separate things go to
your closet find the tool bag get a
drill get that brain If you hear me
you get a lobotomy
trichinosis I believe it is the the
habit of drilling holes yes trichinosis
yeah yes that thing let's all get in get
into phrenology guys okay let's quit our
jobs what we were talking pregnancy
let's get our brains out let's just
switch brains let's do like a freaking
uh what do you call the car with the car
thing where everyone switches seats but
we delve to switch his brains Chinese
fire drones
a good old American Pie America
all right guys so to this uh really
Rogue theory about like Matt Murdock and
Jennifer Walters
um reunion creating a potential baby
what do you guys think you think is
rogus bogus or just regular ogus it's no
secret that Mt and I have a love affair
that is as historic as Romeo and Juliet
it is it transcends time he is my he's
my he's my soul mate we we get each
other we we are able to talk in a
language that is not appealing to anyone
on the internet but we like it but just
check some of our past videos on this
channel go look at the view counts
they're not great but
empty I you know I love you so I say
this with absolute love this is the most
bogus story I've ever heard
[Music]
I love you I hate it so much no no I
know it's still I I tried to go extra
row because I'm like you know what I
usually don't go like super you went so
extra Rogue we gotta charge you yeah we
gotta charge you for that don't let him
talk you out of it but no okay I'll take
that Focus because it is very very out
there super out there but that doesn't
mean I love you any less just so you
know yes we love each other deeply we're
like Tristan uh
[Laughter]
I I was watching this episode and I
gotta say the same thought immediately
came to my mind when they did the deed I
was like could they have a kid what
would that be like that'd be an
interesting thing so I'll give this an
oh guess because I don't think I was
surprised enough that Disney gave us the
joy of of having a Jennifer Walters
who's very sex positive and is having
sex and living your life and doing it
I'm happy with that I don't think they
will give us our beautiful she devil
baby I think it would be great if they
did it but I don't think they're gonna
do it well the she'd never be played by
Roseanne as as his kid
I wish Tommy no what they're gonna do is
they're gonna get that weird [ __ ] up
baby from Twilight to play
We're masterbrand or whatever I want
them to bring back the the fake baby
from American snipers
Whitney uh what do you think about this
Theory like Tommy I gotta say my friend
I mean you know how much I love you you
know that at least a fun fact is that at
the end of every single I'm sorry at the
end of every single office-wide meeting
uh Mt and I are the only two people who
say I love you to each other to close
out a meeting
[Music]
Brandon and I used to say I love you to
each other at our improv theater We
performed at and people got very they it
was really scandalous
I think I really think that Peter three
Andrew Garfield like really opened the
door for Mt and I to do this because now
we're just garfielding baby it's not
weird you're weird if you don't like it
exactly exactly hey life is short just
express your love anytime you can field
your friends sometimes it feels nice
exactly but that being said this is so
bogus dude no way
I will give myself a bogus honestly
um
I'll take like a nice little what if
story about it but like not like well
what if would be good okay I'd accept it
I like that you know the most expensive
comic book I ever bought was a what if
comic book uh and it was what if
Spider-Man joined the Fantastic Four and
it's the first ever what if they ever
wrote
and oh [ __ ] this is a story that's not
fun for the air so uh I'm not gonna keep
telling you uh no I bought it at a at a
Comic Con in Virginia and the sticker on
it was from a comic book store in
Rochester New York where I'm from oh
beautiful they had pulled and it come
full circle to me that's good I love
telling that story it's always a hit
everybody loves hearing it
it's it's the type of story that gets
people going
exactly but up next Brandon has a really
fun theory that he's going to talk about
but first be sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest Obsession shirt Lady
Justice inspired by the She-Hulk series
that is on the TV right now uh you can
also check out our latest Obsession
shirt Ash and ruin inspired by the house
of the Dragon series both of these
shirts are limited edition and won't be
available for much longer so be sure to
grab them while you still can support
the channel and head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com today but we also
want to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
Rogue Theory this week it may be spooky
season but nobody wants to be ghosted in
the bedroom you know what I'm talking
about oh Bluetooth can give you that
extra bit of confidence when it matters
the most when it's time for sex Lucha is
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis but enjoyable tablets and at
a fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day night Twilight Dusk and you
can plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises and the process is
simple sign up at Blue dot com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers they have licenses not like
the guy on the street that you talk to
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days but in the
best part it's all done on the internet
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy Bluetooth tablets
are made in the USA and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package and we've got a special
deal for our listeners try Bluetooth for
free when you use our promo code Rogue
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Rogue to receive your first month for
free so visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank Lucci for sponsoring this
podcast we also want to thank pharity
because if you're looking to up your
wardrobe game this fall then parody has
got you covered Verity is all about
clothing for life's best moments they
make clothes that feel good and that
make you feel good Verity is a family
brand that believes comfort and quality
are key they're passionate about
craftsmanship sustainability and making
clothes that look and feel rate every
piece is designed to be a lifetime
favorite in fact the clothes even get
better with age and if anything happens
along the way Verity will replace or fix
your clothes for life no matter what
later your favorite pieces for a cozy
fall Vibe they've got tons of options
for women and men from their one and
done jumpsuit to their best-selling soft
and stretchy Legend sweater shirt that
has thousands of five star reviews
you're destined to find a new fall
favorite at Verity producer Brandon
loves his Verity clothes and wishes he
could dress in their fall fashions year
round and right now Verity is giving all
Rogue Theory fans 15 off on every order
because we have it we have their the
deals like that you heard me you can get
50 off your order head to
ferritybrand.com Rogue and use the code
Roga checkout to get this amazing deal
that's code Rogue at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com
Rogue for 15 off veritybrand.com Rogue
all right Brandon take it away for the
second theory because it's gonna be a
good one okay uh I've been thinking
ahead looking at that lovely phase five
chart they gave us and we know uh
Captain America New World Order is
coming right and they've already told us
that the leader is coming back which was
quite a surprise for everybody like
we've been waiting mt's been ringing
that Bell for 10 years now but someone
else I think two other folks will be
coming back uh in this Captain America
film I think it's time to revisit an old
Captain America villain that's right I
think the Red Skull is going to be
returning in Captain America new world
order via a Little Help from his good
friend Zola they've been separated for
so long Zola's not dead he lives in the
machine he's in he's out there somewhere
he lives here too he pulled that missile
you know on the bunker to try and kill
Matt uh and Steve Rogers who had
recently had sex
so he was smart enough to know that I
like I'm not going out like this but I
think Zola's going to be able to get Red
Skull back because now that the Soul
Stone has been decimated red skull's
free right he's stuck on homes
he's no longer locked there and like
sorry I think we'll find a way to get
him back and maybe Zola has like
uploaded his Consciousness Consciousness
to some like
spaceships out there you know we had the
Milano yeah the Milano came to Earth
sword Tommy that's a great Point Zola's
in space baby and he's gonna get Red
Skull from vormir bring him back to
Earth and be like let's finish what we
started that's the new world order that
we're gonna get I think that the New
World Order is that Elon Musk purchased
uh Zola in addition to twitter.com
everyone's favorite website
most of the fake accounts are Zola
all the boxers over that's hilarious but
yeah that's what I actually think
they're gonna reveal that at the Moon
indeed they're going to reveal that uh
Red Skull and Zola are going to be back
in Captain America oh I love that that's
a great uh come around I think I want
more Red Skull baby I do too I love this
Theory a lot because I've been I I think
this like wholeheartedly I think that
Red Skull has not done the MCU because
reticle is so much of an iconic villain
in the MCU in that my Marvel history and
like for him to be one and done like in
the Captain America one and like
obviously we had him in an Infinity war
and end game I feel like
um it's time for a Red Skull to come
back because like see if you remember
from Infinity war and end game
um as soon as the sacrifice is made in
vormir a huge beam of light shoots into
the sky which is very suspiciously like
the same space Stone beam that sent him
to vormir in this in the first half the
Red Skull himself got shot and sent to a
different part of the universe and I
think that you know like you said like I
really love that you brought up Zola
bringing the one that's gonna bring him
back because like it makes a lot of
sense because Zola is so dedicated to
that man like it's so crazy how like how
much he loves the Red Skull that like he
would probably and like um someone
brought up the satellite the sword
satellites amazing idea because Zola can
just update upload his Consciousness
there and just like maybe just download
The Red Skull via data because like we
know that um Red Skull is in wraith form
right now he doesn't really have a body
he's just like a a wisp of like dark
smoke or whatever well he had to get
there somehow right so the same way he
got there
was presumably reversible right it would
be cool if it was almost like how in a
lot of movies where there's a magic
spell if you destroy the McGuffin the
spell is undone right so if the stones
being destroyed what if that just that
automatically teleports him back to
Earth and he's just hanging out in
Germany he's like what happens
oh [ __ ]
it just drops right into the ocean oh
I can't swim
Zola point is good because Marvel
doesn't leave a lot of loose ends right
and Zola is kind of one of the very few
Marvel loose ends that we don't have I
mean I guess we was he he came in what
if right yeah they showed that he's
still around and what if so I imagine
he's still got to be around and I hate
to be a hater but for whatever reason
what if doesn't register to me as much
as the other MCU thinks because it's a
cartoon and I and I'm I know but
yourself you know I'm an animation
specialist go [ __ ] yourself
how dare you you offend me you offend my
family
[Music]
I think it makes perfect sense for them
to come around in the fourth movie with
a new Captain America to foil right like
it's not Christmas yeah yeah it's a
modern Captain America all the more
confusing for kind of both of them I
guess maybe Zola has adapted because
he's just been adapting with technology
but Red Skull for sure is going to be
like wait what what are we doing here
which one I'm sorry the Kardashians you
can vote now like wait hold on what's
going on wait people can vote now they
can read Captain America I don't I don't
know what's going on with this world
Davidson got out with what how do I know
who Pete Davidson is what does he know
what does he know I do think it's also a
great opportunity to reveal that Chris
Evans Captain America Steve Rogers is
still alive when like Sam Wilson has to
call him up and be like how do I fight
this guy I don't want him to still be
alive so old let him rest no Jesus
let him die this is like you are keeping
him alive purely for your own
entertainment hey a lot of us are
depending on very old people to stay
alive right now yeah yeah I need him to
live it's like my parents he is not
permitted to die yet he is not permitted
to die I understand that but he's
literally hundreds of years old
I'm saying let Steve Rogers take a take
a little snooze like I I would love for
Steve Rogers to like have like a nice
peaceful rest
um Eternal rest but like there's no way
Marvel Studios is going to not on my
watch
um let Steve Rogers die we need the
content baby the mouse won't let anyone
rest easy
[Laughter]
I think eventually like well I think
eventually we'll have Tony Stark and um
Steve Rogers back like actively alive in
the end I think you're right but like
now
um it's it's gonna happen because like
they're huge money makers and like they
have it in the comics like they were
like oh yeah Tony Stark and they're gone
then they came back it's gonna it's
gonna happen
um all right stay dead stay dead stay
there
dude we already had a zombie strange do
you know how sick and [ __ ] up that
thing looked no I don't want Robert
Downey Jr coming back less hot I'm sorry
this it may be that selfish of me I love
you good thousand
years
he's gonna say I love you Z thousand
because
nose falls off
yes well I if we have to vote on this
let's vote on it let's vote on this
let's do it this is getting 100 brogus
for me majorly for me as well like
double rogus because like the Red Skull
is not done the MCU Zola's too much of a
kiss ass to let him go
honestly I'm just like oh you guys kiss
already like we get it please
just do it that's like a workplace
romance that you know I think that we
all see coming yo if imagine if like
Zola just professes his love with the
Red Skull it's like listen I've always
loved you and you just like
maybe he rolls with it you just kiss the
computer screen it's like I love you
yeah so we'll have to we'll have to see
will The Red Skull Garfield him back or
will Zola just be me and Mt in a meeting
only one saying it right he's like all
right thanks guys we'll be back next
week I just got I just got the call back
to Garfield I thought you thought
Garfield the cat yes
Garfield famously say I love you back to
people and I was like oh yeah oh yeah
to Mondays every Monday he's just like I
love this Monday so much that's not true
you don't know Garfield lore you're
exposing yourself fake Garfield fan I'm
a fake Garfield stand this guy's some
he's he's an imposter wait did we all
vote on like oh yeah yeah
oh my God triple rogus this makes
Brandon our our big I mean we don't do
winners but like yeah we'll do what is
this episode makes Brandon our winner
for today's Rogue Fury with the most
roses
yeah the smartest boss the smartest boy
in the whole world
my sweet boy I love you my sweet boy but
now it is time for our Rogue question
are you guys ready for this one yeah
let's do it kind of spooky because now
that werewolf by night has made its way
into the MCU and opened up the cabinet
of monsters what Rogue battle would you
like to see happen between a Marvel hero
or villain and a classic movie monster
so like you know you could do like well
Tony Stark and uh the Invisible Man why
am I breaking out a monster The Mummy I
don't know yeah or or you are right
there the Invisible Man yeah
that's very classic I've done it's
classic I'll go with one that I was
pitching earlier Tommy unless you want
it no take it I've got one I think you
got to take you gotta take uh
resurrected Man versus resurrected man
built by scientists not supposed to be
here torn asunder you have uh
Frankenstein or what you're not what you
might call Frankenstein's monster but
we'll call it Frankenstein for for for
bonding here uh versus Vision they're
two monstrosities that have to fight
each other but yeah I want to see
Frankenstein versus Vision in a battle
for science experiments Superior I like
it which one deserves to live I have a
feeling that freaking science monster
has no idea what the ship of Theseus is
so uh yeah you can't logic your way
around Frankenstein
he doesn't care he can't you know you
want to know something really messed up
when I was a kid my friend's mom uh used
to show us Frankenstein and when that
part where he kills the little girl
would come on she'd be like you get what
happened you get do you understand
what's happening here and we'd all be
like yeah he's like and then she'd be
like she's he's killing a little girl
and we would go yeah we know and we
don't like it uh but she loved that part
that was her favorite part so shouts and
Brian shouts to her I'm going to call
Bogus on your friend's mom that is
terrible
she also thinks that uh Confederate
monuments shouldn't be torn down I mean
a lot of them
let me pitch my thing the invisible man
has become insufferable he is releasing
statements that are inflammatory he is
making headlines he's sexist he's a pig
he's rude he's thoughtless enter Sue
storm
[Music]
stuff keeps getting knocked over yeah
all right uh please please know that in
my heart I consider this a yes and and a
contribution to Brandon's already
Stellar Theory I'm not trying to copy
piggy but whatever however I would like
to say Vision versus Young Frankenstein
because that would be hilarious
[Laughter]
[Music]
I love this I love all of these but I've
got to give it a Tommy for Invisible Man
versus invisible woman
I would love to see you back it's a
scene of that just happening and also
just I mean I feel like in every
iteration The Invisible Man becomes a
insufferable problematic I mean at
certain points it becomes a rapist
murderer but in the Tamer versions he
just becomes an [ __ ] so no matter
what the Invisible Man always is like oh
I have this power to not be seen I'm
gonna I'm gonna break bad so I I think
he needs too much power
The Invisible Man is in charge of
Intelligentsia
but that is it for this really unhinged
episode of Rogue Theory I love each and
every one of you this was amazing thank
you to Whitney van letting him Tommy
bechtold and Brandon Barrett for joining
me on this wild ride you can support our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com do not forget and if
you got thoughts on some of our Rogue
theories you can share them on our
Discord so if you're over 18 search for
new Rockstar's Discord server and join
the conversation today you can follow me
at masterton if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] you can follow new
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
the YouTube machine thank you guys so
much for spending time with us we
appreciate you guys times a million
we'll see you guys next time bye bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]